on est bien chez toi j'ai mal au ventre
je sais plus si c'est géré le corps une
fois encore envie d'y échapper
c'est la chronique yami ouais enfin
cyril avait envie du tout je vous
l'avais dit je vous le dis depuis
plusieurs jours chez comme un poids
ouais ouais une petite boîte
ah non mais je vous dis j'ai pris des
médicaments je ne vais plus au toilette
norvège où il n'y a plus jamais non peu
pareil pour quelles que soient nos jours
et voilà c'est juste un poil à voile à
bas les basses vallées faut que je
souffre
allez faites votre émission toute façon
c'est votre cas est choquant un pub
inscrit qu'un bond champions bon alors
les amis qu'est-ce que j'ai regardé je
suis même plus parce que je vais pas
faire cette analyse je pense pas comme
ça ses préférences mais la somme que
j'aille pis m
[Applaudissements]